Ministry of interior troops
I'd like to thank you for the
preparation training which you underwent
to avert the Rebellion but a special
role was played by you
and York role was played by you
and your comrades
and
I'd like to convey special words of
gratitude to you for that because we
understood what was happening and what
would have happened had you not averted
this Mutiny and you did that by
fulfilling your military duty and being
loyal to the oath to safeguard the
country as always happens in such cases
always and everywhere the same thing
happens after an armed uprising
you get complete chaos and Civil War
so
that's what you averted that's what you
prevented that was your role and for
that as commander-in-chief of the Armed
Forces I owe you a debt of gratitude
I would just like you to understand what
it's all about and I'm going to tell you
now
unfortunately
you had to work in very difficult
conditions so as to
so as to protect the civilian population
and
I
also regret even more that we suffered
losses
there were losses unfortunately
our comrades perished defending the
motherland
and I say that without any kind of
pathos or sentimentality I'd just like
to emphasize the fact that the country
would have been plunged into chaos
without you
and
that's what was attempted to be done I
shall say
something further about that later but
it wasn't successful but certainly
it was exploited
all those achievements
which
or many of them
of our country would have been lost in
the process and you did not allow that
to happen
without any doubt
I've always said this to the minister
everything will be done so as to support
the uh families of our
of our bearish comrades
we have always respected
enormously the our comrades in the uh
Wagner
um Complete because they showed a huge
amount of heroism
and our soldiers and officers and
Volunteers in the Russian army uh worked
very performatively well in combat
they also showed heroism self-sacrifice
and
those people who had already worked in
the Wagner company uh commanded respect
I'd just like to just note though and I
want everybody to know this that
the Wagner group was entirely funded by
the state
from the budget of the ministry of
Defense the state budget
it
completely funded the group
from May to uh
June 22 the state paid Wagner
more than
806 billion rubles
and then another 7 billion rubles 15
billions
and
many other billions to the insurance
the preparator of the Concord company at
the same time Cherry Smith Turk
through the ministry of trade
the upkeep of the Wagner company was on
the uh on the shoulders of the state but
the head of the uh company also earned
800 billion rubles
so the upkeep of the company was
entirely uh the responsibility of the
state
this Concord company but at the same
time
800 billion uh rubles were earned
by the Concord company uh
let's put it this way
billions were earned
but
when I talk about this matter I just
like to say the following
you have done an enormous amount in
order to make sure that the combat was
properly performed
let me just uh clarify my information as
from the fourth
of June
that is to say against the
counter-offensive of the ukrainians
uh the ukrainians lost to 250 uh tanks
and
only in the oregov region
the adversary
only over the last seven days
lost to 250 units of equipment and 41
tanks
or armored cars this is significantly
down to your work
and I think that that is all to your
benefit
I have instructed the Minister of
Defense of course
to make sure that uh
payment is made to all those who took
part in the events
I've already said to the minister and
I'd just like to repeat it once again
that
those who
demonstrated
uh demonstrated a particular prowess or
courage they aren't really the backbone
of the Russian armed forces and uh I
commend you for it
I'd like to conclude on that note
and thank you once again for all the
work which you have done for Russia and
for the country thank you very much